hello nymphets so good to see you again
today mr. Rogers hosted this show called
mr. Rogers neighborhood in which he
calmly and patiently sent out a message
that it's okay to be confused and I like
you just the way or there was always
something you can do with the mad that
you feel he had a mission to engender
understanding and kindness we are truly
to get the world positive ways of
dealing with her feelings his ability
for empathy was enormous what he could
do immediately to any person with any
kind of problem any human condition was
related to it sometimes we have to ask
for help and that's okay he was just
this beloved figure who saw goodness and
everybody you love broken people like me
I don't think you were broken he always
gave somebody a chance to just be
special on their own without any
expectations thank you for that
perspective hearing Fred's voice is
really reassuring in these times there's
something about his message that feels
more important now than ever I think the
best thing we can do is to let people
know that each one of them is precious
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]